A PAPER CLIP IS HER TROMBONE.
DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE" ."
STORMY DANIELS LAWYER, THE
ESTEEMED MIKE ALANI WAS ARRESTED
ON SUSPICION OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE FOR THE WHOLE
STORY IS PRETTY MURKY BUT IT
SEEMS HE'S ACCUSED OF SIMILAR --
ACCUSED OF SIMILAR STUFF.
I'M NOT GOING TO LIE, I FELT
LIKE THERE WAS SOME ADJUSTMENTS
EXACTED IN THE UNIVERSE.
I MAY BE SMALL FOR FEELING THAT
WAY BUT NOBODY IS AS SMALL,
PETTY, IRRESPONSIBLE AS THIS
GUY.
HE TRIED TO RUIN BRETT
KAVANAUGH'S LIFE.
THAT WRONGDOING REQUIRES SERIOUS
POETIC JUSTICE.
EVEN IF IT TURNS OUT HE'S
INNOCENT AND HE MIGHT BE, HE'S
TASTING THE KIND OF PAIN HE'S
PUT ON OTHERS AND IT'S GOOD TO
SEE ONE LEADER OF A MOB GET
HOISTED ON HIS OWN PITCHFORK.
ONE MUST RESIST -- WE MUST BE
BETTER THAN HIM AND BETTER THAN
AVENATTI.
THAT IS A LOW BAR.
WE MUST BE MAGNIFICENT COMPARED
TO HIM, SO HE DESERVES DUE
PROCESS AND THE PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE EVEN IF HE KEPT IT
FROM KAVANAUGH.
HE MUST GET ALL THE GOOD STUFF
OUR SYSTEM HAS TO OFFER EVEN IF
HE WOULD HAPPILY DENY IT TO YOU
ARE TO ME.
MAYBE IF JUSTICE IS SERVED, HE
MIGHT LEARN SOMETHING ABOUT HIS
OWN BEHAVIOR, HIS OWN SINS IN
HIS OWN.
BUT HE'S MY GLOVE AND 90, SO
DON'T HOLD YOUR BREATH.
HE BELIEVES HE WAS SET UP.
WOULD YOU BE MORE LIKELY
DEMOCRATS THAN REPUBLICANS TO
FRAME HIM?
[LAUGHTER]
A CROWDED FIELD AND HE DOESN'T
DO THE DEMOCRATS ANY FAVOR.
YOU REALLY THINK HE'S RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT?
I THINK AVENATTI IS REALLY,
THAT'S REALLY RIDICULOUS.
SEEMS TO BE A LOT OF
SCHADENFREUDE AROUND TODAY WITH
REGARD TO MICHAEL MENOTTI.
TOWN HALL HAD A HEADLINE.
SWEET IRONY.
I THINK WE SHOULD ALL BE VERY
CAREFUL.
WE DON'T KNOW THE FACTS OF THIS
CASE AND I WAS SURPRISED THAT
THE FIRST WIFE AND SECOND WIFE
SAID SHE WASN'T THERE AND THE
INITIAL REPORT WAS THAT SHE WAS
THERE AND SHE WAS THE VICTIM.
WE ARE LOCKED INTO THIS TRIBAL
POLITICAL FRAMEWORK.
IF YOU ARE A TRUMP SUPPORTER,
WHY NOT TAKE THE LIGHT.
>> Greg: DANA, AS MUCH AS I
DESPISE THE GUY, YOU HAVE TO
PRESUME HE'S INNOCENT EVEN IF HE
WOULD SCREW YOU OVER IN A
HEARTBEAT.
>> I SAW A COUPLE
"NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTERS ARE
GOING TO BE WRITING A BOOK
COMING OUT NEXT YEAR AND IT'S
GOING TO ANSWER ALL THE
QUESTIONS, STILL UNANSWERED
QUESTIONS FROM THE BRETT
KAVANAUGH CONFIRMATION HEARINGS
AND I THOUGHT ALL THE QUESTIONS?
THE ONES INCLUDING THOSE
REFERRED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE BY THE GRASSLEY
COMMITTEE FOR MAKING FALSE
STATEMENTS.
THOSE UNANSWERED QUESTIONS?
IT WOULD BE INTERESTING.
>> Greg: IT WOULD BE A GREAT
BOOK.
IF THE BOOK WAS FOCUSED ON TWO
WEEKS, IT WOULD BE A GREAT BOOK.
I KNOW IT'S SMALL AND I AM SMALL
BUT I FEEL SOME JUSTICE TO SEE
HOW AVENATTI RESPONSE NOW THAT
HE'S ON THE OTHER SIDE.
>> Jesse: ISN'T IT FUNNY HOW
LIFE CAN HOLD A MIRROR UP AND
SHOW YOU LESSONS LEARNED.
IT WAS A COUPLE MONTHS AGO THAT
THIS EXACT SAME THING WAS
HAPPENING TO BRETT KAVANAUGH
ALLEGEDLY AND HE WASN'T GIVING
HIM THE BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT.
EVENT HAPPEN TO THIS PERSON AND
THIS PERSON, THE ENTIRE MEDIA
CAN STEP BACK AND SAY INNOCENT
UNTIL PROVEN GUILTY.
EXCEPT HILLARY, BECAUSE WE KNOW
SHE'S GUILTY.
YOU LOOK AT THIS GUY, IT'S
LOOKING LIKE HIS 15 MINUTES OR
UP.
LET'S SAY SOMETHING HAPPENED
THAT WAS BAD.
HE RODE THE LAWSUIT TO FAME.
AND HE'S NOW BEING INVESTIGATED
FOR LYING TO THE SENATE.
A JUDGE RULED HE OWES MILLIONS
TO HIS BUSINESS PARTNERS.
HE'S ACCUSED OF FELONY DOMESTIC
ASSAULT.
RETHINKING HOW BAD CAN IT GET
MANY SAY IT'S GOING TO GET A LOT
WORSE BECAUSE HE'S NEVER GOING
TO GET BOOKED ON ANY CABLE NEWS
SHOWS ANYMORE.
EVERYBODY THAT LOVED HIM, CNN
BARELY COVERED THE STORY.
HIS APPEARANCES AT VERMONT AT
SOME DEMOCRATIC EVENT OR
CANCELED.
THIS GUY IS A PARIAH AND IS IN
THE MIDDLE OF A REALLY DIRTY
DIVORCE RIGHT NOW AND HE CAN'T
AFFORD THE LUXURY LIFESTYLE HE'S
PROVIDED FOR HIMSELF AND HIS
EX-WIFE.
I THINK WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
IS HE WAS GOING TO TAKE THE
MONEY RAISED FOR THE
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN AND I
THINK HE WAS GOING TO PAY DOWN
DEBT WITH THAT BECAUSE HE OWES
HIS BUSINESS PARTNERS AND HE
OWES THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE IRS MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
THAT'S OVER WITH.
THE SHELL GAME HE WAS TRYING TO
ARRANGE IS DONE.
I THINK HE WAS GOING TO PROBABLY
DECLARE BANKRUPTCY OR HE MAY
SPEND TIME IN PRISON.
>> Greg: YOU ARE THE OPPOSITE
OF A THERAPIST.
YOU BASICALLY TOOK APART EVERY
FACET OF HIS CAREER.
>> Jesse: HAVE BEEN FOLLOWING
HIM CLOSELY.
HOW CAN YOU NOT?
HE'S ON TV ALL THE TIME.
>> Greg: JEDEDIAH, EVEN ALYSSA
MILANO WHO WAS FRONT AND CENTER
OR IN THE BACK OF THE KAVANAUGH
HEARINGS HAS DISAVOWED HIM.
>> Jedidiah: SHE IS CONSISTENT
ANYWAY.
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE DOESN'T
MATTER TO HER.
YOU ASKED HOW HE MIGHT RESPOND
IN ONE OF THE THINGS HE TWEETED
WAS WHY IS TMZ THE NEWS
STANDARD?
THAT'S WHAT SOME OF US HAVE BEEN
SAYING.
NOW HE'S GOING TO BE THE GUY WHO
QUESTIONS THESE NEWS OUTLETS AND
SAYS WAIT, THIS IS AN
ACCUSATION, AN ALLEGATION.
THERE'S NO PROOF.
HE'S MAKING THE EXACT SAME
ARGUMENTS EVERYONE WAS WATCHING
KAVANAUGH SAYING HOLD ON THE
SECOND.
LET'S INVESTIGATE IT AND FIGURE
OUT WHAT HAPPENED AND NOT
CRIMINALIZE THIS GUY.
NOW HE'S MAKING THOSE ARGUMENTS.
THEY SHOULD BE A MOMENT FOR HIM,
A TURNING POINT MOMENT FOR HIM
WHERE HE SITS BACK AND HE'S A
DECENT HUMAN BEING AND I DON'T
KNOW HIM PERSONALLY BUT IF HE
IS, HE SITS BACK AND CAN SAY
WOW, THIS IS WHY THIS MATTERS.
AT ANY POINT, YOU COULD BE IN
THE SITUATION.
ANYONE OF US COULD BE IN A
SITUATION OR THE PUBLIC DOESN'T
KNOW THE STORY BUT YOU DESERVE
THE RIGHT TO BE INNOCENT UNTIL
PROVEN GUILTY BECAUSE NO ONE
ELSE KNOWS THE STORY EXCEPT YOU
AND YOU HAVE TO GO THROUGH
PROCESS.
NO ONE GAVE KAVANAUGH THEIR
RIGHT TO PROCESS AND NOW HE'S
SEEING THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
DON'T WANT TO GIVE HIM THAT SAME
RIGHT AND MANY OF US ARE SITTING
HERE -- I DON'T AGREE WITH HIM
ON ANYTHING BUT I'M HERE TO
DEFEND HIS RIGHT TO PROCESS THE
SAME WAY I WAS DEFENDING
KAVANAUGH'S RIGHT TO PROCESS.
>> Juan: YOU REALLY THINK, AND
JESSE SAID THIS, YOU THINK IT'S
ANALOGOUS?
I THINK YOU'RE BEING UNFAIR TO
KAVANAUGH.
KAVANAUGH, THE HARD CHARGE
AGAINST HIM CAME FROM PROFESSOR
FORD WHO SAID SOMETHING HAPPEN
WHEN HE WAS A TEENAGER AND THEN
THEY HAD TO GET HER TO TESTIFY
IN THERE TRYING TO FIND IF THEY
COULD CONFIRM.
IN THE CASE OF WHAT WE ARE
SEEING WITH AVENATTI, YOU'VE GOT
THE WOMEN RIGHT THERE THAT THE
INVESTIGATION IS ONGOING.
I DON'T THINK IT'S ANALOGOUS AND
I DON'T THINK IT'S ANALOGOUS TO
STORMY DANIELS SAYING SOMETHING
HAPPEN WITH DONALD TRUMP AND
THEN DISCOVERING THERE WAS A
PAYOFF.
NOW EVERYTHING IS ABOUT THE SAME
AND IT'S ALL ABOUT DUE PROCESS?
>> Jedidiah: STILL HAS A RIGHT
TO MAKE HIS K HEARD -- CASE
HEARD.
>> Jesse: KAVANAUGH WAS 30
YEARS AGO.
THIS IS AN ACTUAL ARREST.
>> Juan: THAT'S WHAT I JUST
SAID.
THAT'S WHY IT'S NOT ANALOGOUS.
THE BURDEN OF PROOF IS MORE ON
AVENATTI.
>> Jedidiah: WHAT IS ANALOGOUS
IS THAT THE PUBLIC SHOULD BE
WILLING TO SAY INNOCENT UNTIL
PROVEN GUILTY.
IT IS STILL AMERICA REGARDLESS
OF THE SITUATION.
IT'S NOT THE SAME SITUATION.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
THERE IS AN ARREST HERE AND IT'S
ARGUABLY WORSE FOR HIM.
PEOPLE HAVE A RIGHT TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES AND WE SHOULD BE
CRIMINALIZING PEOPLE.
>> Jesse: AS I GET MORE FAMOUS
AND POWERFUL, I'VE NOTICED
SOMETHING.
I'M PROBABLY GOING TO GET SET UP
AT SOME POINT.
I HAVE SOME GREAT ADVICE FOR
PEOPLE.
I SOUGHT ON TWITTER.
IF YOU ARE TRAVELING ALONE FOR A
PERIOD OF TIME AND NO ONE KNOWS
WHERE YOU ARE, IT'S GOOD TO MAKE
PURCHASES WITH A CREDIT CARD OR
DEBIT CARD.
THERE IS AN ELECTRONIC FOOTPRINT
THAT VERIFIES YOUR WHEREABOUTS
AT A CERTAIN POINT IN TIME SO
YOU HAVE AN ALIBI.
SO NO ONE CAN SAY YOU DID THIS
TO ME AT THIS TIME.
YOU LOOK      CAN LOOK AT THE RC
YOU LOOK      CAN LOOK AT THE RI
YOU LOOK      CAN LOOK AT THE RT
YOU LOOK      CAN LOOK AT THE R.
I WAS AT THE 7-ELEVEN.
>> Juan: WHAT HAPPENED WHEN
YOU GAVE ME YOUR STARBUCKS CARD
AND I USED IT?
YOU ARE SETTING ME UP.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: IF EVERYBODY WOULD DO
THAT, EVERY CRIMINAL WOULD DO
THAT.
>> Jesse: I AM SAYING IT
HELPS.